programming throwdown episode 112 trees take it away jason, everybody. So this is going to be a pretty cool episode. Another duo episode, as we talked about a little earlier. We got some awesome folks. Literally, the company is called Awesome Pros. So check them out if you're interested for your podcast. But we got some awesome folks helping us out on the editing recording side. So we're able to produce more content, which is super exciting. And we've had a bunch of ideas. We have a whole list of ideas lined up of stuff that we want to
chat about. And today we're going to be talking about trees, computer trees, although there is that whole thing about planting a million trees. Have you heard about that? On YouTube? I thought, you know, that's funny. I thought the same thing. People are going to assume we're talking about fundraising for planting trees. Yeah. Honestly, I don't know very much about it. I thought, you know, that's funny. I thought the same thing. People are going to assume we're talking about fundraising for planting trees. Yeah. Honestly, I don't know very much about it. I mean, it sounds cool. Sounds like, you know, planting trees sounds like it's pretty, you know, universally like a good thing to do. But no, this is about computer trees. Yeah, we're going to dive really deep into that. But first, we'll talk a little bit about avoiding drama at work. So dramatic, you know, this,
so there is, you know, a lot of sources of drama at work. There are, you know, political things, there are various sort of social situations, or like, I don't know, social phenomena. I mean, there's also just, you know, other than the macro stuff, there's also just like what we call like office politics. You know, this person, you know, is in a bind and they kind of backstab this other person. And then, you know, there's all of this drama. And I'm here to tell you to avoid the drama. And we're give some tips on how to avoid drama at work. You know, maybe we'll just ping pong back and forth. I mean, my biggest thing, my biggest piece of advice that really like it's, it's actually, you kind of influence people just by being yourself, right? And so you don't really have to go out of your way to tell people how you feel about things that are like, besides the work you're doing, right? So I mean, you know, just by being,
you know, yourself and having opinions that you're proud of, you know, and all of that, you know, that that's kind of in my opinion, that's kind of enough. Right. I mean, you don't then have to, like you might see a lot of things and feel compelled to say, oh, like I want to argue with this or I want to go back and forth, you know, and the way that you kind of think about things is already being expressed just through you being yourself. You don't also have to kind of take the extra step. Yeah, I think I, what you're saying is like over time, sort of being consistently acting in a manner which is true to those things that you think, then you kind of like express them into your work environment. Yeah, exactly. And another thing too is, you know, there was a situation a really long time ago where,
you know, someone had done something that I felt was not right. Now, of course, like if there is issues with, you know, harassment or anything like that, you know, of course you need to speak up. I mean, that is extremely important. But I'm just saying, I mean, this wasn't anything like that. But it's something where I kind of felt really compelled to kind of, you know, start kind of a discussion that that was probably not gonna be very productive. And I decided, you know, no, I don't really want to kind of get into this kind of stuff at work. And then actually, what ended up happening is, and this took a little bit of it took, it took a while, you know, it's not something that happened overnight. But but eventually, that person, you know, ended up kind of losing a lot of their authority and their and their seniority and things at work. And the thing I realized from that
experience was, you know, at that moment, I felt like, you know, there was this kind of real attack on me personally, and that I had to stand up for myself. But then, you know, there was this kind of real attack on me personally and that I had to stand up for myself. But then, you know, in hindsight, it was obvious that, you know, this person kind of had a problem with everybody. It really had nothing to do with me. I was just one of the people that this person was interacting with. And now there is sort of a tragedy of the commons. Like you could you could say to yourself, well, if no one does anything, then this sort of toxic person might just continue being toxic forever.
And so you do have to kind of balance that out. But at the same time, I think it's so easy to go the other way and kind of get into a really big battle that is ultimately just going to take a lot of your time and energy and resources and will just not really be productive for anybody. This is going to come across sounding a lot like self-help. Yeah. Well, I mean, I think it's a... Actually, I saw a study that said the number two reason why CEOs get fired is actually like public scandal, which the number one reason is performance.
So, I mean, that's kind of a no-braer, right? People get fired for performance, especially at that high of a level. But, you know, the number two reason is effectively, you know, some type of like public faux pas or something. And that's huge when you think about all the other reasons someone could get fired. I mean, they could get fired for like maybe they had some financial problem, like they had a financial error. And so like, you know, the SEC gets involved. There's all these other reasons why a CEO could get terminated. But that was number two. Right. And so. So, yeah, I think it's a really poignant topic.
And I guess the biggest thing is, is just to always just keep a level head and kind of keep your cool. And especially, you know, at work, I think I also don't really understand why people argue political stuff over the internet. But if you're going to do it, at least do it over the internet, not at the water cooler or something. At least do it pseudonymously and not in person. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. All right. So that's that's my rant about avoiding drama at work. It's so important and it takes a lot of fortitude. But I think at the end, you're always going to look back and say, I'm really proud of myself for having that kind of reserve. Right? Makes sense. Yeah, that's hard to follow up, man. I don't know. That was a heady opening topic. All right. We'll jump into the news then. The news is much more benign. Okay. No, good stuff. Good stuff. Yeah. Yeah. A drama. My completely unrelated to drama is my
first link is C++20 new features with example. This article that I found shows almost all of the new C++20 core features and gives a little like code snippet for how each of them works. Now, this is obviously like gonna make sense to a subset of the subset of a subset of our audience. I always find this like it's so useful because to me, I always, someone was showing, you know, recently we went to C++ 17 at work.
And although, you know, that's an upgrade and still a few years old, it takes a while for these things to kind of roll out if you're not familiar with C++17 at work. And although you know, that's an upgrade and still a few years old, it takes a while for these things to kind of roll out if you're not familiar with C++. And someone was like listing off the new features. And all I'm doing is like, I don't even know what that means. Like, what was it? There was like the ternary operator. And I'm like, I don't even know what the or the trigraph. We knew what the ternary operator is. But there's something like the trigraph operator is been deprecated in C++17. i don't know what that is like go look it up is that the thing
with the question mark and the colon that's the ternary operator that one's still good okay but there's a trigraph operator which i i don't even remember what it is now it's like question mark angle bracket angle bracket or something and i have i didn't even know it was a thing, which is why it's been deprecated. Anyways, so seeing a list like this was super helpful for me to be able to realize like what these named things actually meant. Because I know it means something very specific and language is very important. And the C++ standards committee, I'm sure worked very hard to make sure it makes sense, but it doesn't make sense to me. And so seeing the code examples allows me to quickly discount 90% of them
as not useful to me. I mean, it helps me to understand what these new features are. I'm not a big fan of jumping in and using all of the new features, but it's definitely helpful to kind of see them written down. So I really appreciated this article.
I will have a link in the show notes because it's on someone's GitHub page and it's really long. So I'm not going to say it out loud. But if you're used to C++, you're interested in seeing what new features are in 20, check out the show notes
and definitely visit this link. What was the version that added lambdas? That was the last big feature. 13 or 11? I think 11. Oh, it's that old? Now lambdas and then, well, actually one that came out,
it might be in 20 or it might be in 20 where it's not experimental anymore, is the file system library. That was another really important one. Ah, 17. Yeah, okay. Those are the two I remember where I was like, oh, we totally needed this for such a long time.
Cool. All right, my news is play Co-op Diablo 2 in the browser. So there's always this interesting kind of march towards, you know, doing just more and more exotic things in the browser. So this is, you know, I know a while back MAME was ported to the browser. This is using like Emscripten and these other technologies like WebAssembly. And so, you know, one of the challenges, though, for something like this is, you know, the network stack, right? Because you can't really run a server, for example, in the browser and have other people, or maybe you can. Let me think about that.
Actually, you kind of can using WebRTC and stuff like that. But it's definitely not a one-to-one mapping between, you know, these low-level kind of Windows sockets or Unix sockets and what you can do in the browser. And so, you know, that's kind of been an area where you haven't seen a lot of development. But here they actually have Diablo 2. And I'm assuming they, you know, don't have the source code or anything like that. So this is, you know, just using the diablo 2 binary you are able to actually play in the browser and it's able to talk to a diablo 2 uh you know battle.net server and you can actually play with other people co-op online without even having to to really do it download
anything you just visit a website which is pretty wild i mean i'll have to do a bit of research into how this actually works my guess is maybe they hacked the like DOS box emulator. And so and so they somehow wrote a translation layer, where when you try to create a Windows socket, it uses uses WebRTC, which is just pretty amazing, or WebSockets or something like that. Pretty amazing. Check it out. It's clouddiablo.com. We'll have a link in the show notes. But I thought that was pretty wild achievement there. That is really awesome. And now I'm going to get depressing. I remember playing Diablo 2 when it came out and I was not a super young person when it did and playing it, really enjoying it,
playing a lot. Do you know when Diablo 2 came out? You know, I've never, I played Diablo 1, just the demo. I only played the demo though. So I've never been into the whole Diablo thing, but yeah, go ahead. I only played the demo though. So I've never been into the whole Diablo thing, but yeah, go ahead and tell us when did it come out? 2000. So it's 21 years older. It will be 21 years old in June. Oh man, that's nuts. Yeah, that's right. I remember right around, uh, that would be senior year of high school for me. Oh, now you just, oh no, no, no. People are doing the math in their head, man. Yeah, I'm going to hit the big 4-0 in, I guess, 10 months or something.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Diablo 2 had, if I remember correctly, Diablo 2 was the one that actually had like an overland map, right? Because the one I played was just, you're in a town and there was a dungeon and that was it.
But then 2 added like a whole world, right? Yeah, like you walk around and then you go into dungeons. Yes. Yeah. Yeah, the Diablo around and then you go into dungeons. Yes. Yeah. Yeah, the Diablo games are actually pretty fun. I enjoy them. I don't know.
For me, there's like a whole layer of complexity, but I never really got into it as like, you know, number crunching and min-maxing your character build-outs. Like I never got competitive like that. I always just sort of like wandered around and like, you know, smashed a lot of stuff. And I always thought that was fun.
But I never got super, super into it. But a lot of people really did. And for me, games that allow both kind of players are super awesome. There's a lot of recent games that people get really into that I don't feel support casual or semi casual play. Yeah, yeah, I totally agree with that. You know, the games I've been getting into lately have been racing games and i've been considering buying a steering wheel oh the challenge is um if you buy a steering wheel you uh you also they all come with the pedals and i feel like you can't really use the pedals if you're standing up and i have a standing desk so it's like it's like it's starting to spiral out of control it's like okay first i need to buy a bucket seat and then I need to buy, you know, with the hydraulics to make it react to you. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm not sure what to do. I'm a little bit of analysis paralysis, but I think maybe I did see there's some steering wheels that have like basically like a grip. So like the harder you grip, the faster the car goes.
And so I might try and pick one of those up. Interesting. I think you need to like come up with a custom like DDR style map for... Oh, that would be awesome. I've been playing this game Wreckfest. I just want to give a shout out to Wreckfest. They're not a sponsor or anything, but Bugbear is a company and they made this game Wreckfest.
It's really interesting. So you have 24 racers. 20 are what you'd expect.'re just in cars they're racing around the track etc the other four are in giant heavy school buses and their job is to go around the track backwards and wreck like the people in in the top three positions so like so you'll be driving it could be an oval or whatever but like you'll be driving around the track and all of a sudden like a school bus will just crush you. So it's kind of like the blue turtle in Mario Kart. Are they computer controlled or like it's like an ASM, like some players are playing
one and some players the other. Yeah, no, they're all real people. So it's kind of like if the blue shell was sentient. It's just crushed. Oh man. It is really, really fun. Highly recommend Wreckfest. so it's kind of like if the blue shell was sentient it's just crushed oh oh man it's really really fun highly recommend wreck fest i actually you know i never buy cosmetic stuff like just buy a new skin for your car whatever i never really done that but i actually went and bought a bunch of cosmetic stuff in wreck fest i don't even use it i just i put so many hours into that game that
was like these guys deserve more than the 20 bucks or whatever it was. Interesting. I'll have to check that out. So your news article was Diablo 2 in the browser, talking about browser games, but on a completely different level. This was something I came across that I thought was like super cool. And one of those things, which we have said probably 500 times in the podcast, which is like, I wish this was around when I was learning to program.
And that's Kaboom. And the URL is replit.com slash Kaboom. And so I guess Replit is, they have a free tier, but it's also like a paid service, like IDE in the cloud, where you can run code and do development and stuff. I can't vouch for it, I haven't tried that. But this Kaboom thing is they were able to host
a JavaScript game development library. If you do nothing else, search it and watch their opening video, which is hand-drawn MS Paint pixel art with just a hilarious run-up. And the audio is made by them. The drawing is made by them. And it's not meant to be the next blockbuster AAA title game engine.
It's literally like, oh, I want to drop a character here. And then it's like, you know, draw the sprites for your character's animation sequence. And you draw them in a little pixel editor. And then, you know, draw the wall tile and you draw the wall tile. And it manages the assets and your video game thing and it's kind of not really like a definitely not a no code way of building it but just sort of this like right at your fingertips like everything sort of kept right there and i imagine for complex games it gets out of hand really fast but for just making super simple like a side scrolling engine
and uh doing ascii descriptions of your text level, like equal signs for the walls and plus signs for where you want item pickups and doing those kinds of things in a very simple environment, but something that really gets you into programming and allows you to make these. I think they look pretty cool, retro, nostalgic looking games. I thought this was a really cool thing. Kaboom.js. I actually wonder, this was a way to try it easily in the browser, which is how I was able to play around with it for a few minutes. But they may have, I'm not a big JavaScript person, so I don't know how people pick up JavaScript libraries normally. But it looks like they also have,
you don't need to go only on Replit. They have a way to do it if you want to just host it yourself and try it. they have it available as well at kaboomjs.com oh that's awesome i'll have to check that out and so so the idea is you you draw the map in ascii but then you for each like ascii character you have a picture attached to it or something yeah you just like has like the assets right there and you say like invent a new asset and then it just gives you a little pixel editor and asks you to draw it oh very cool you have to check this out all right my topic is on remote work and so so patrick and i are both uh well everyone is working remote but you know at some point um offices are going to reopen and i don't know patrick if you've what your plan is or
you know or anything like that. But in my case, I'm permanently remote. So this is the real deal forever and ever. Oh, ever and ever. That's a big commitment. I mean, who knows? But yeah, I mean, I'm basically a remote employee permanently. And so this whole like, oh, maybe remote wasn't a good idea. Article is definitely scary to somebody who's really there's no going back.
But yeah, I think it's an it's a really interesting debate. And honestly, I don't have a lot of answers or insights, really. I mean, I think that so far being remote has been really great. I think we might have talked about this. I think we talked about this. We talked with Kevin. But yeah, we both have loved being remote. But then the question is, when people come back into the office, what's the hybrid solution?
That's really what it is, where it's maybe there's four people who are all sitting next to each other and another four people who are spread out around the globe. How do you keep the social environment healthy and fair and all of that in that kind of world. And I think that's, that's what this article is kind of positing. And I don't know if there are really any answers yet. Yeah, I think that's going to be a hard question for people like what is the future look and then the debate we were even having at work the other day is, is this a kind of one and done thing? And like, it just slowly over time returns back to normal? Or like, is this going to keep creeping up, there will be at least for some while people's
concern that it may come back, or that, you know, the next version, you know, the in in Silicon Valley, I guess the whole open office densely packed people real estate at a super high premium is kind of very incompatible with the view that there might be reasons to not be super close to people. And so it's very interesting to see how we'll run a sort of real life experiment in the various ways of solving the problem over the next couple of years. Yeah, that's another really good point. I mean, a lot of companies in the Valley will have to double their office space, right? Because the density, do you think they're going to have laws around the density? Or do you think it'll be mostly like self governance? I mean, laws is one of those things that's tough, right? Like at best
case, I think laws are sort of slower, slower moving, slower to catch up, which makes sense. I actually think that, you know, too fast lawmaking, you might end up in a problem. And so I think what will happen is the employees in some ways will sort of express what they're comfortable or not comfortable doing. And especially if there's a, like, I think what will happen is the employees in some ways will sort of express what they're comfortable or not comfortable doing. And especially if there's a, like, I think Silicon Valley had gotten quite homogenous in the approach. And I think this will shake it up and allow for some experimentation to take place, which I think traditionally has been where you see a lot of innovation happen, right?
And so I think we might be entering an era where you see some interesting innovation around this and a lot of people trying things and the ones that will succeed will attract people to them away from the ones that are on the other end of the spectrum. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, one thing that I don't know if I mentioned this on the show, but one thing I've been thinking a lot about is, like, is it possible and like, sort of safe from a privacy standpoint to like decouple your kind of work team and your social team like like you know look at we work for example right so we work is this company or this this idea where you know they have a big office and you might go and rent one cubicle in this giant office and the person next to you and a person on the other side of you work for totally different companies you're just sharing this like you know a physical space right
and so you know if you wanted to go start like a ping pong club you could do it with the people around you even though you know the 12 of you work for 12 different companies and so i wonder if that is going to if that idea is really going to fly where, you know, it's, it's like you kind of have a group of people and you have a whole relationship with them, but then you also have like your work team, which is spread out throughout the whole globe. And it's sort of like two different social networks, right? Not to get back into the avoidant trauma work you're talking about before, but I think it's been interesting. This thing you're saying a little bit reminds me of something
I've thought some about, which is the different way different people treat their sort of work team. And some people, the team becomes like a extension of their family, which makes sense. I mean, you spend, used to spend, you know, 40 hours a week minimum with those people basically. And in some ways that's more awake time than, you know, 40 hours a week minimum with those people, basically. And in some ways, that's more awake time than, you know, you often spend with other members of your family. And so for some people, they sort of really bring those people in and treat them as family. Other people want to maintain a separation, right, between their sort of work teammates, and they can be sort of work friends with them. But there's a difference between a friend and a work friend,
and they maintain that pretty solidly. And then, of course, people all along the spectrum. And then of course, people who have no interest in sort of the social aspects at work. And I've always thought it's interesting that how a person approaches that problem impacts how the work evolves, right? So how the manager treats the team and their personal life separation probably colors how they view people on their team's treatment of work stuff. That is, that was a really vague way of saying it. But like, if you come to work and your managers are very like super, everyone's my friend, let's hang out all the time. And you want to maintain a stronger separation that creates a bit of awkwardness. And so I actually think this thing you're saying, Jason, where like they get separated for ill or good, I'm not sure. But at least it's sort of evens out that some if people
realize I'm not going to be at work all the time, or we enter a hybrid or a mostly remote work, then people really understand that separation. And it's sort of somewhat forced in. And you can still have fun with the people at work, but it's a little bit different. And I think that will even out the people who maybe felt trepidation or awkwardness with those relationships before. Yeah, that's a really good call out. And so then as a thought experiment, what happens to the other people like the people who, you know, always want to go golfing with the boss or something, but now the boss is, you know, 1000 miles away. Maybe maybe people have that personality will will just won't be remote, right? They won't be remote employees. Yeah, I don't know. Maybe they seek out a team or environment where,
for some reason or another, they sort of need everyone together, or that's a culture thing, or whatever. Yeah, yeah, it's interesting. Yeah, that's pretty wild. Yeah, I think, yeah, I'm really curious to see what's going to happen. I wonder to what degree like technology can help with something like this. Yeah. I mean, it's hard to know because we're not really in that situation yet. Like it's hard to kind of project what that's going to look like and what the social feelings are going to be, you know? I mean, I, for one, welcome our telepresence humanoid robot desk mates. Oh, man. All right. Cool. So on that note, book of the show. My book of the show is Debt, the First 5,000 Years. I have to confess, I haven't read this yet. I just got it. But I'm always looking out for books on finance. Finance
or just the history of finance is just super interesting to me. And somebody at work sent me a ping maybe a couple of weeks ago. And they said, hey, I read this book. I think it's right up your alley. And so I'm just catching up with... I finished Anti-Fragile. And so I'm just kind of getting caught up with my current books and jumping into this new book. So I haven't read it yet, but it does seem really cool. I think that if you think about it, the whole thing around debt and credit and lending is really, really fascinating. In my case, I try not to have any debt if possible. I mean, there's things that, there's large purchases that you have to pay over time, like you buy a house or something like that. But, you know, on the credit card and some of these things, you know, I try not to have debt, but at the same time, I don't preload anything either. So the credit card is super, super useful because I can make a payment on something that has zero balance using something that has zero balance, using something that has zero balance, and then pay it later. And so I think... And then, of course, if for whatever reason I didn't pay it, well,
now it's like there's debt. So it's like you can't really have a credit card without debt. So it's unavoidable if you want to have that level of convenience. And you can ask yourself... I mean, there's a lot of really fundamental questions about debt that I have. And I think this book will clear a lot of them up. One of them is, and Patrick, tell me your take on this, but if something is backed by the government, I still don't quite understand why they could charge interest. You know what I mean? if you're not actually taking any risk. Because in effect, the person who's paying the loan as a citizen of a country that's ultimately backing the loan is actually taking the risk and giving you interest. So that's just one thing. But debt is really fascinating to me. And I think this book is really going to explain a lot of stuff. Yeah, I think I'm going to opt out of getting into an in-depth fractional reserve banking
discussion and interest just now like in here i this is gonna avoiding drama i don't want so okay a couple of things so one thing is is uh yeah i look at it just just super objective i don't have like a horse in the race per se i just try to learn as much as possible but the other thing is is what is fractional reserve because you mentioned that a while back and i always meant to ask you off the air, and I never got a chance. So what is fractional reserve banking? What does that mean? So you kind of were bringing it up by saying, you were admitting the realization that the bank borrows money from the government at some level before lending out money. So the naive way of viewing a bank, and I might mess it up, I'm going to try. The naive way is that the bank has somebody come in and say, I'm going to give you $100.
刚刚我们讨论到兴趣，比如说在这里，这能避免戏剧化的争端，我可不想要，所以好吧，有几件事，首先是，呃，我只是以超级客观的视角来看待它，我本身并不在这个竞争中有什么切身利益，我只是尽量多学一点，但另一件事是，什么是部分准备金？因为你前不久提到过这个，我一直想在节目外问你，但一直没机会。那么，什么是部分准备金银行业务？那是什么意思？所以你之前提起过它，承认了这样一种认识，即银行在放贷之前，在某种程度上会向政府借钱。因此，用天真的眼光来看待银行，我可能会说砸了，但我还是想试一试。天真的看法是，银行会让人进来，然后说：“我要给你100美元。”
And then they say, cool, we're going to pay you 0.001% interest on your $100. Then they go find a mortgage customer who says, oh, I want to use $100 to buy a house. And you go, okay, cool. I'm going to loan out my $100 to you that I got from this other person. And then you can use it to pay the person you're buying the house from. And then what I now have is someone who believes the $100 is at the bank, but in actuality it hasn't. It's been given to someone to buy a house and that person is making payments. And then the hope is that when the payments come in,
接着他们会说：“太好了，我们会按你的100美元支付0.001%的利息。”然后他们去找一个按揭贷款客户，那个人说：“哦，我想用100美元买一套房。”你就会说：“行，没问题。我要把从另一个人那里拿来的100美元借给你。”然后你就可以用它来付钱给你买房的那个房主。接下来我手头上的情况是，有个人相信那100美元在银行里，但实际上并没有。它已经被借给别人去买房了，而那个人正在还款。然后，人们的期望是，在款项收回之前，
that the person doesn't come and ask for their money back before it's there. So you can't loan out money that you don't have unless you have a way of borrowing it. So the question is how much of the amount of money that you have loaned out, your obligations, your liabilities for a bank, do you need to have in reserve? And that fraction that you need is sort of governed by the government saying like, you have to have this. Now, the difference is that you can also sort of borrow money. But what happens with the whole fractional reserve banking, if banks borrow money from each other or from the government and keep a small amount in a reserve,
这个人不会来把钱要回去。所以，除非你有办法借到钱，否则你不能把没有的钱借出去。因此问题在于，在你借出去的钱当中，也就是你的债务和银行的负债中，有多少需要作为准备金保留下来？你所需要的这个比例是由政府规定的，政府会要求你必须拥有这部分资金。现在，不同之处在于你也可以某种程度上借钱。但是，整个部分准备金银行业务会带来什么影响呢？如果银行互相借钱或者向政府借钱，并把一小部分作为准备金留存下来，
and say someone takes out a loan at bank A and then deposits it in bank B and starts earning interest and then takes it out again and puts it somewhere else. Now, if you ask each of the banks, each of the banks will say like, oh, I have $100 deposited times three banks. But what if you've just gone in a circle? You actually only ever had $100. Oh, and so fractional reserve banking is pointing out this thing that you can sort of artificially create money by not requiring that banks fully back
比方说，有人在A银行贷款，然后把钱存入B银行并开始赚取利息，接着又把它取出来存到别的地方。现在，如果你去问每一家银行，每家银行都会说：“哦，我有100美元的存款，乘以三家银行。”但如果你只是兜了个圈子呢？实际上你自始至终只有100美元。哦，所以部分准备金银行业务指出的就是这样一件事：通过不要求银行全额支持存款，
the deposits. Oh, I get it. Oh, it's interesting. And so the government can sort of, by controlling what percentage of liabilities are needed to being held and by the interest rate at which they're willing to loan new money and do these audits, they can sort of have a, I guess, not a direct, but an influence over sort of how much total money is circulating out in the environment. So by lowering the interest rates from the government, they can encourage the banks to lend out money because they can lower their rates, which are like a delta on top of the government's rate. And so they can encourage people to take loans by making interest rates lower and lower, and thereby cause sort of inflation, right? There's more apparent money in the system. I probably didn't get that 100% right, but that's the gist. Yeah, yeah. No, it totally makes sense. I mean, basically, if the government has a really high
你可以凭空创造货币。哦，我明白了。哦，这真有趣。因此，政府可以通过控制需要持有的负债百分比、愿意以多高的利率出借新资金以及进行这些审计，来对环境中流通的总货币量施加一种——我想这不能算直接控制，但算是一种影响。所以，通过降低政府的利率，他们可以鼓励银行放贷，因为银行可以降低自己的利率，这利率是在政府利率之上的一点加价。因此，他们可以通过不断降低利率来鼓励人们贷款，从而导致某种程度的通货膨胀，对吧？系统里表面上的货币变多了。我可能没有百分之百理解对，但大致就是这个意思。对，对。没错，这完全说得通。我的意思是，基本上，如果政府有很高的
interest rate, then you could invest in that. I don't know what you would call that, investing in, I don't know, the government or something. Yeah. You buy treasuries. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right. No, I know like the vehicle, but it's like, what are the treasuries actually doing? It's like building bridges or something. They're a bond backed by the government. So it's a government taking out a loan from you. Oh, I got it. So it's basically just going to whatever the government pays for. It could be anything. Yes. And so, and so, yeah. And, the higher the interest rates go, the more people who are going to do that. And that means there's less people who want to invest in other private things. And so I think right now the interest rates are very low. And so people are always looking for
利率，那么你就可以投资于那个。我不知道你会怎么称呼它，投资于，我不知道，政府什么的。对。你买国债。对。对。对。没错，我知道那种金融工具，但国债实际上在做什么呢？就像是建造桥梁什么的。它们是由政府担保的债券。所以这是政府向你借款。哦，我明白了。所以它基本上就是用于政府支付的任何开销。什么都可以。是的。所以，所以，是的。而且，利率涨得越高，这样做的人就越多。这意味着想要投资其他私营领域的人就越少。所以我觉得现在利率非常低，因此人们总是在寻找
things to invest in. So real estate and other things. Yep. Okay. Yeah. That's going to get, if we keep going down this path, another few steps, it's going to get dramatic and political. Okay. All right. Let's not do that. The other thing I was going to bring up here that's interesting. So I've read the first sort of 50 pages of this book.
可以投资的东西。比如房地产和其他东西。没错。好吧。是的。如果我们继续沿着这条路走下去，再走几步，事情就会变得戏剧化而且充满政治色彩。好吧。好了。我们别这么做了。我要在这儿提的另一件有趣的事是。所以这本书的前50页左右我读过了。
Well, listen to the equivalent of about the first 50 pages of this book, because I have this book on Audible, but I haven't made it through. It's definitely not the most exciting read, at least in the first few pages. But I also am intrigued by this concept. And it also plays into the thing that we've been a common theme here on the show, which is the cryptocurrency and blockchain and this concept of DeFi, this distributed finance.
嗯，听完了这本书前50页左右的音频，因为我在Audible上有这本书，但我还没看完。它绝对不是最引人入胜的读物，至少在前几页是这样。但我也对这个概念很感兴趣。这也契合了我们节目中的一个常见主题，那就是加密货币、区块链以及DeFi这个概念，也就是去中心化金融。
And how would you allow on the blockchain people to borrow money by depositing one asset and taking money out of some sort of contract and going and using that money and then paying back that debt over time? And how would you handle that if it needed to be done all via algorithm and not by human intervention or judgment? Wow, that's actually in the book? No, no, no. I don't think so. I'm just saying this conversation we're having about fractional reserve banking, inflationary versus deflationary politics, and the common theme of cryptocurrency leads to a very interesting topic if anyone wants to go sort of look in that and
以及你将如何在区块链上允许人们通过存入一项资产并从某种智能合约中取出资金，然后去使用这些资金，随着时间推移再偿还这笔债务？如果这一切都需要完全通过算法来进行，而不是靠人类的干预或判断，你该如何处理它？哇，书里真的有这个吗？不，不，不。我想没有。我只是说，我们刚才关于部分准备金银行业务、通胀与通缩政策的讨论，以及加密货币这个常见主题，引出了一个非常有趣的话题，如果有人想去了解一下，
hasn't yet about this distributed finance. I don't think it's in the book. I haven't seen anything about crypto derivatives. I mean, I'm sure it exists, but it's definitely not a popular thing. Oh, the book was written in 2011. So yeah, there's zero chance it's in there. Oh, yeah. Oh, there you go. I think crypto derivatives would be a pretty interesting thing. But then the thing is, how do you do that? Because derivatives have to trade faster, presumably, have to trade at higher cadence than the original thing. And crypto is so slow. I mean, you have to somehow make the algorithm, that whole process be much faster. My book of the show is not well suited to audio edition in the format I'm going
并且还没看过关于这种去中心化金融的内容的话。我觉得书里没有。我没看到任何关于加密衍生品的内容。我的意思是，我确信它是存在的，但它绝对不是一个热门话题。哦，这本书是2011年写的。所以，是的，这里面完全不可能有。哦，是的。哦，原来如此。我觉得加密衍生品会是一个相当有趣的事物。但问题是，你该怎么做呢？因为衍生品必须以更快的速度交易，想必必须比原资产以更高的频率进行交易。而加密货币太慢了。我的意思是，你得想办法让算法和整个过程变得快得多。我为本期节目推荐的书不太适合我接下来要推荐的那种音频格式，
to recommend it. But that is Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone, the illustrated edition. So we've talked about before, both Jason and I have children, and my children are now old enough to sort of start introducing them to Harry Potter and they're getting interested in reading. And so I figured to to read to them, I would read Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone. And then I decided to go in and pick up the illustrated edition just to kind of keep it more engaging for them, unless at least until we saw how it went. And oh, man, I harry potter i don't even know how long ago i'm like long ago uh when back like when they were first coming out it also it came out around the time diablo came out oh did it i think so yeah correct me if i'm wrong
不过那是《哈利·波特与魔法石》的插图版。所以我们之前谈到过，我和杰森都有孩子，我的孩子们现在已经到了开始接触《哈利·波特》并且对阅读产生兴趣的年龄了。所以我想给他们朗读，我打算读《哈利·波特与魔法石》。然后我决定去买插图版，好让他们更有代入感，至少在看到效果如何之前是这样。天哪，我读《哈利·波特》——我都不知道那是多久以前了，很久很久以前，大概是它们刚出版的时候。它好像和《暗黑破坏神》差不多是同一时期出来的？哦，是吗？好像是的，没错。如果我记错了请纠正我，
i'll look it up but going back through it again and reading it and then like also seeing the pictures are so well done in this book these books books aren't cheap, like I've gotten used to like really cheap books. These books are just very well done though the drawings, even the pages that don't have sort of full color illustration have like texture to the page. And it's not just a black and white. Small knit is like there are some places where the text is a little hard to read against the background. But just like thematic and sort of, you know, nice to look at and just a really nice like thematic and sort of you know nice to look at and just a really nice book to read and and sort of go page by page through i've really enjoyed that so harry potter and the sorcerer's stone came out in 1997 we're gonna keep going uh so
我会去查证的。但再次重温并阅读它，然后看到这本书里的图片画得是真好。这些书可不便宜，我已经习惯了那种非常便宜的书。不过这些书确实制作精良，插图甚至连那些没有全彩插图的页面都有特殊的纸张质感。而且不仅仅是黑白。有些地方，背景色让文字稍微有点难读。但单就主题和观感而言，（或者说）画面很好看，是一本非常棒的、有主题感、看起来很舒服的书，让人忍不住一页一页读下去，我真的很享受。所以《哈利·波特与魔法石》是1997年出版的，我们继续——所以，
so if you've not if you're interested in harry potter or if you have children or if you've never read it before or if you just really like pictures, you know, I don't think it's probably everyone who's into this has probably seen these before. But anyway, my recommendation is Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone. So it's not a small book, right? So how does that work? Is there a picture every few pages? Or is there one every page? Or what's the... So the I mean, the book is both large in sort of height and width and then also it's sort of normally deep so it's a little bigger than a normal book but you would not want to carry this book to the beach and read it on the beach oh got it or whatever like it's a bigger book
所以如果你还没有——如果你对《哈利·波特》感兴趣，或者你有孩子，或者你以前从未读过它，或者你真的很喜欢图片，你知道的，我想并不是每个人——对这个感兴趣的人大概以前都看过这些。不过无论如何，我的推荐是《哈利·波特与魔法石》。所以它不是一本小书，对吧？那它是怎么样的？每隔几页就有一张图？还是每一页都有一张？或者说……所以，我的意思是，这本书在高度和宽度上都很大，而且厚度也很正常，所以它比普通的书要大一点。不过你可不会想带着这本书去海滩并在海滩上阅读它，
and then you know also and there's you know so every page has like some sort of like thematic texture drawing to it if i recall but then yeah it's sort of every other page or every third page pair will have like some picture related to the thing sort of like off to the side or in the corner. So is it a bridged or is it like actually the whole book? No, it's the full thing. Wow, that's cool. Yeah, I find out about so many good products on this show. This is like, what is that? Oprah who does the Christmas best things or things you have to buy? Yeah, that's right.
诸如此类的，它是一本大书。然后你知道的，每一页都有某种主题纹理的插图，如果我没记错的话；接着，是的，大概每隔一页或每三页会有一幅与内容相关的图片，放在旁边或者角落里。所以它是删节版还是整本书的原貌？不，是完整版。哇，太酷了。是的，我在这个节目里发现了好多好产品。这就像是什么来着？奥普拉每年圣诞节都会评选最棒的东西或者你必须购买的东西吗？对，没错。
Yeah, very cool. I'll definitely be picking that up. So I alluded to it. And I actually do have Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone on Audible, but it's obviously not illustrated, but it is well narrated. And it's a very pleasant way to consume the book.
是的，太酷了。我肯定会去买一本的。所以我刚才暗示过了。其实我确实在Audible上有《哈利·波特与魔法石》，但它显然没有插图，不过它的旁白讲得很好。这是一种非常愉悦的听书方式。
But if you've never tried Audible before, you can check it out and help sponsor the show by going to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown. And there they'll do a free one month trial of Audible, which you can pick sort of any book that's in Audible, download it and you get to keep that book. And then you can cancel the trial if you decide you don't want to keep it
但如果你以前从未尝试过Audible，你可以去看看并通过访问 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown 来赞助本节目。在那里，他们提供为期一个月的Audible免费试用，你可以挑选Audible上的任意一本书，下载它，并且这本书就归你了。然后，如果你决定不想继续使用，你可以取消试用，
or keep going and get a book a month. I've done that for a while. You also get access to their sales and I've built up quite a collection. But honestly, I really enjoy it. I don't have a bookshelf at home with dozens and dozens and dozens of physical books. It's just not a thing I do anymore. But I do enjoy actually scrolling through my Audible list of books and picking out my recommendations for this show. Yeah, very cool. And for folks who either already have an Audible account or are interested in that, they can support us on Patreon. So Patreon and Audible are how we can keep this show going and how we were able to get
或者继续下去，每个月获得一本书。我这么做好一阵子了。你还可以访问他们的特卖活动，我已经攒了相当多的藏书。但说实话，我真的很喜欢它。我家里的书架上并没有几十本、上百本的实体书。那已经不是我现在的做派了。但我确实很享受浏览我的Audible书单并为这个节目挑选推荐书籍的过程。是的，非常酷。对于那些已经拥有Audible账户或对此感兴趣的人，你们可以在Patreon上支持我们。Patreon和Audible就是我们能够维持这个节目继续办下去以及能够获取
more content. I mean, this episode exists because of your support. And so we really appreciate that. You can reach us at patreon.com slash programming throwdown. It's time for tools of the show. My tool of the show is Vagrant. Have you ever used Vagrant, Patrick? Or are you new to Vagrant?
更多内容的方式。我的意思是，这一期的存在就是因为你们的支持。所以我们非常感激。你可以在 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown 找到我们。又到了本期节目工具推荐的时间。我本期推荐的工具是Vagrant。帕特里克，你用过Vagrant吗？还是说你对Vagrant很陌生？
I feel like I know the word, but I'm not thinking of what it is right now. Okay, so Vagrant is, it's similar to Docker. We talked about Docker on an earlier episode, but it is for virtual machines. So Vagrant is a way to spin up a virtual machine and to initialize it with a set of parameters and a set of scripts. So for example, I use Vagrant a lot
我觉得我听过这个词，但现在想不起来它是什么了。好的，Vagrant是，它类似于Docker。我们在之前的节目中讨论过Docker，但它是针对虚拟机（VM）的。所以Vagrant是一种启动虚拟机并使用一组参数和脚本对其进行初始化的方法。例如，当我测试新版本的Eternal Terminal时，我经常使用Vagrant。
when I'm testing new versions of Eternal Terminal. So before I release a new version, which is kind of a big process, it goes to all the Debian and Fedora, like official, like the package systems, and it runs through a million different tests. People will download it. I want to make sure that at least like all the tests run and build and everything and so i have a set of vagrant scripts and so the way this works is similar to docker you know you write a vagrant file and in that file you say what the virtual machine should be like should it be ubuntu should it be windows should it be you be Fedora or OpenSUSE or whichever one? And then you specify the things like how many CPUs should the virtual machine have, etc. And you can specify scripts.
所以在发布新版本之前——这是一个相当大的流程，它会进入所有Debian和Fedora的官方软件包系统，并运行上百万个不同的测试，供人们下载——我希望确保至少所有的测试都能运行、构建成功以及一切正常。所以我有一套Vagrant脚本。它的工作原理类似于Docker，你知道的，你编写一个Vagrantfile，在这个文件中你指定虚拟机的属性：它应该是Ubuntu、Windows、Fedora、OpenSUSE还是别的什么？然后你指定诸如虚拟机应该有多少个CPU等配置。你还可以指定脚本。
So in my case, the script goes to GitHub, grabs the latest eternal terminal release, and builds it and runs all the tests. And then kind of exits, right? and builds it and runs all the tests and then exits. All of that is nice because, for example, there was a GitHub issue the other day where someone said, I don't know how you pronounce this. It's OpenSUSE, but that variant of Linux wasn't compiling. I just pointed them to Vagrant.
所以在我的例子中，脚本会访问GitHub，获取最新的Eternal Terminal版本，构建它并运行所有测试。然后就退出了，对吧？构建它并运行所有测试，然后退出。所有这一切都很棒，因为，举个例子，GitHub上几天前有个问题（Issue），有人说——我不知道怎么发音，是OpenSUSE，但那个版本的Linux无法编译。我直接指引他们去看Vagrant。
I said, hey, install Vagrant, run Vagrant up in this directory, and you'll see it totally builds and works. And it turns out that the person who actually maintains the OpenSUSE package, who isn't me, that person, there was some error there. I don't actually know the details,
我说：“嘿，安装Vagrant，在这个目录下运行vagrant up，你会发现它完全可以构建并正常工作。”结果发现，实际维护OpenSUSE软件包的那个人（不是我），那里出现了一些错误。我其实不知道具体细节，
but I was able to just get anybody to just go on there and run and build. It's just super convenient. Now, you might say to yourself, well, if you have Docker, why do you need this, right? And the answer is, there is that layer in between Docker and the virtual machine, right? There is the whole, the Docker, like Docker Daemon, right? And so Docker tries to, you know, be really good about, you know, giving you a lot of freedom and flexibility when you're doing things like building packages, or especially you're doing things which involve low level networking. You know, that can give you results that aren't really natural. And sometimes
但我能够让任何人直接上去运行和构建。这实在是太方便了。现在，你可能会对自己说：“既然有了Docker，为什么还需要这个呢？”答案是，在Docker和虚拟机之间还有那么一层，对吧？有整个Docker，比如Docker守护进程（Daemon），对吧？所以Docker试图在你在做诸如构建软件包之类的事情时，或者特别是当你做涉及底层网络的事情时，为你提供大量的自由度和灵活性。你知道的，这可能会带给你一些并不那么自然的成果。有时候
you really need like a bare bones virtual machine. And so Vagrant is kind of like the Docker for that kind of stuff. So if you need that, check it out. It's super, super useful, especially if you're deploying software on a bunch of different OSs. You know, I literally have just one script that I run and I can test every OS. And when the script finishes, I know like every OS works. So it's just a one liner. And so I'm a big fan of Vagrant. Nice. Maybe, you know, what is the difference between something like Vagrant and VirtualBox? Oh, yeah. So under the hood, Vagrant uses VirtualBox. I think of Vagrant is just like a scripting library for VirtualBox. That's a good way of looking at it. I see. I see.
你真的需要一个精简的基础虚拟机。所以Vagrant就像是那种事情的Docker。因此，如果你需要这个，去看看吧。它超级超级有用，特别是如果你要在各种不同的操作系统上部署软件的话。你知道的，我字面意思上只需要运行一个脚本，就能测试每一个操作系统。当脚本运行结束时，我知道每一个操作系统都能工作。所以这只是一行命令，因此我是Vagrant的超级粉丝。太棒了。也许，你知道的，Vagrant和VirtualBox之类东西的区别是什么？哦，是的。在底层，Vagrant使用的是VirtualBox。我认为Vagrant就像是VirtualBox的一个脚本库。这是一种很好的看法。原来如此。我明白了。
Okay. The other thing it does is it maps like a folder on your computer to a virtual machine. So if I do like vagrant up in a certain folder or with a certain vagrant file, it has a UUID for that file. And if the machine already exists in virtual box, then it won't have to like totally destroy it and bring it back up and stuff like that. Nice. My tool of the show, i actually had one and then i switched it to a collection because indecisiveness i was playing a new game by uh zach gauge games and that was good sudoku so i played sudoku for a while i got off and on in books but i never really got into it just didn't feel the same like i couldn't use my pencil to kind of make notes
好的。它做的另一件事是将你计算机上的某个文件夹映射到虚拟机。所以如果我在某个文件夹中或者使用某个Vagrantfile运行vagrant up，它会为该文件分配一个UUID。如果虚拟机已经在VirtualBox中存在了，它就不必完全将其销毁再重新启动等等。太棒了。我本期推荐的工具，我本来有一个，然后因为优柔寡断我换成了一个游戏合集。我一直在玩由扎克·盖奇游戏（Zach Gage Games）制作的新游戏，那是《好数独》（Good Sudoku）。我以前玩过一阵子数独，断断续续地在书里玩过，但从来没有真正迷上过，因为感觉不太对劲——我无法像在纸上那样用铅笔做笔记
on iPhone or, you know, on an Android phone. I use an iPhone, but I'm sure it works the same. And so, you know, I kind of never really did it, got into it on mobile. But then I tried this good Sudoku and I didn't realize it was by the Zack Age Games, but I tried it and they just like the kind of UI they built up around playing Sudoku.
在iPhone上，或者（你知道的）在Android手机上。我用的是iPhone，但我确信它在安卓上的体验是一样的。所以，你知道的，我从来没有真正在手机上沉迷过它。但后来我尝试了这款《好数独》，我当时并没有意识到它是扎克·盖奇的游戏，我试了一下，他们围绕玩数独构建的用户界面（UI）
It's not exactly the same as how i would do it on pencil and paper it plays a little faster but that's actually what i want and i just really thought it was as very well done and then i realized like i was searching this you know zach gage games this is the maker of of good sudoku and then i'm like oh i actually like a lot of these games so they're the people that made Ridiculous Fishing, Really Bad Chess. So Ridiculous Fishing is like you're a dude on a fishing boat and then you use like the motion sensor in your phone to drop a line down into the depths of the ocean,
和我在纸笔上的做法不完全一样，节奏稍微快了一点，但这实际上正是我想要的。我真的觉得它做得非常棒。然后我意识到——我搜索了这个（你知道的）“扎克·盖奇游戏”，这是《好数独》的制作者，接着我想：“哦，其实我很喜欢这些游戏。”原来他们就是制作《荒诞钓鱼》（Ridiculous Fishing）、《极烂国际象棋》（Really Bad Chess）的公司。《荒诞钓鱼》的玩法是这样的：你是一个渔船上的老哥，然后利用手机里的运动传感器把鱼线放进海洋深处，
catch a fish and then sort of reel it back in. It's ridiculous. Did you reach the end of that game? No, uh-uh. Oh, okay. Do I need to? I'll spoil the ending after you explain it. No, don't spoil it. No, you can tell me offline. Okay, okay. Do I need to? I'll spoil the ending after you explain it. No, don't spoil it.
钓上一条鱼，接着把它卷回来。这太荒谬了。你玩到过那个游戏的结局吗？没有，呃-哈。哦，好吧。我需要去通关吗？在你解释完之后，我会剧透结局的。不，别剧透。不，你可以线下告诉我。好吧，好吧。我需要去通关吗？在你解释完之后，我会剧透结局的。不，别剧透。
No, you can tell me offline. Okay, all right. I won't spoil it. I won't spoil it. No, I need like a week. Give me a week. I'll go do it. Now I know there's an ending.
不，你可以线下告诉我。好吧，好吧。我不剧透。我不剧透。不，我需要大概一周时间。给我一周时间。我去把它通了。现在我知道它有结局了。
The ending's actually pretty good. Oh, okay. So really bad chess is, you know, I know Jason is like a master chess person, so we're not going to ignore him for a second. But I'm really bad at chess, actually. So in in this game they don't even try to make an attempt that the sides white and black are even it does effectively randomly place uh chess pieces on your side of the board so you might have like five queens and the other person has all pawns or something where you go in
结局其实挺不错的。哦，好吧。所以《极烂国际象棋》是——我知道杰森是个国际象棋大师，所以我们先暂时不理他一会儿。但实际上我国际象棋玩得真的很烂。所以在游戏中，他们甚至不会试图去让白方和黑方的开局变得公平，它实际上是在你的棋盘一侧随机放置国际象棋棋子，所以你可能会有五个王后，而对方全是兵什么的，或者你只有
one king or something you know and then you try play. So the expectation is just to like be a little more goofy and a little free and make it not have to be this super serious chess game. Anyway, so if you've never checked out any of these games, good Sudoku, really bad chess, ridiculous fishing, some are available on iOS, some on the Play Store, go check them out. They're actually this, I didn't know anything, I need to go learn more about this company. But it turns out right before the show just doing research it turns out actually really into these games now i'm going to follow them and watch for new ones to come out oh very cool yeah the really bad chess sounds awesome do you play online with people or is it against the computer you know i i played it once and i i don't do online playing so i actually don't know if you
一个国王之类的，然后你试着去玩。因此，大家的预期就是稍微搞怪一点、更自由一点，不用把它当成一场超级严肃的国际象棋比赛。总之，如果你从来没有玩过这些游戏中的任何一个：《好数独》、《极烂国际象棋》、《荒诞钓鱼》——有些在iOS上可用，有些在Play商店可用，去看看吧。它们真的——我之前一无所知，我需要去更多地了解这家公司。但事实证明，就在节目开始前做研究时，我发现自己现在真的迷上这些游戏了，我要关注他们并留意他们的新作发布。哦，太酷了。是的，《极烂国际象棋》听起来棒极了。你是和别人在线玩，还是和电脑对战？你知道的，我只玩过一次，我不怎么玩在线对战，所以其实我不知道你
i'm sure there's probably like this based on it. There's a way to do it multiplayer. It's just for me, I never, it always feels embarrassing, even though it's anonymous. Like, I don't want to lose to real people. I don't care about losing to the west coast i actually set up a meetup group called uh sports for people who are really bad at sports okay and uh it was great because you know you kind of self-select for people who aren't going to take it real seriously and it actually i was worried that like somebody would see that title and be really good at ping pong and then just kind of embarrass us and like have to deal with it but no actually like everyone who showed up genuinely was really bad at sports and we all had a really fun time. Oh, that's cool. It does not look like really bad chess has multiplayer.
能不能。我确信基于此肯定有某种多人游戏的模式。对我和来说，我从来——总觉得很尴尬，尽管它是匿名的。比如，我不想输给真人。我不在乎输给西海岸的人。我甚至建立过一个名为“运动白痴运动俱乐部”（sports for people who are really bad at sports）的聚会小组，好吧。这太棒了，因为你知道的，你会自发吸引那些不会把这看得太严肃的人。我本来还担心会有人看到这个名字，结果乒乓球打得极好，然后把我们虐得很惨，我们还得应付那种情况。但并没有，实际上每个出现的人都真的运动神经很差，我们都玩得非常开心。哦，太酷了。《极烂国际象棋》看起来似乎没有多人模式。
It looks like it's only single player. Oh, okay. It kind of makes sense because I think that could be more frustrating. I think it's supposed to be more like, it's kind of like puzzly, right? Like they sort of know like, here's the best you could do
它看起来像是纯单人游戏。哦，好吧。这倒也说得通，因为我觉得（加了多人模式）可能会更让人沮丧。我想它原本就应该更偏向于益智解谜类，对吧？就像他们某种程度上心里有数：面对这堆稀烂的棋子，你能做出的最好走法是什么。如果你玩多人游戏，而另一个人对你取得了明显的绝对优势然后赢了，那又怎样？
with this crappy set of pieces. And if you played multiplayer and one person got like a decidedly a good advantage against you and they win so what yeah exactly like like like teasing apart the computer's kind of strategy is part of the fun and a part of it's kind of gone if you go online hey everybody we have a new sponsor and that is configCat. I'm going to tell you a little bit about what ConfigCat is. It is a feature flag service. You can easily use flags in your code with ConfigCat libraries for Python and nine other platforms. Toggle your feature flags visually on the visual dashboard. Hide or expose features in your application without redeploying your code. Set targeting rules to allow you to control who has access to those new features.
对，完全如此。比如，摸索电脑的某种策略是乐趣的一部分，而如果你去网上对战，这种乐趣就荡然无存了。嘿，各位，我们有一个新赞助商，那就是ConfigCat。我来向大家简单介绍一下什么是ConfigCat。它是一个功能标志（Feature Flag）服务。你可以借助ConfigCat针对Python以及另外九个平台的库，在代码中轻松使用标志。在可视化控制面板上直观地切换你的功能标志。无需重新部署代码，即可在应用程序中隐藏或显示功能。设置定向规则，以便控制谁有权访问这些新功能。
ConfigCat allows you to get the features out faster, test in production, and do easy rollbacks. With ConfigCat's simple API and clear documentation, you'll have initial proof of concept up and running in just minutes. Train new team members in minutes easily so you don't have to pay extra for growing teams. With a simple UI, the whole team can use it effectively. Whether you're an individual or a team, you can try it out with the forever free plan. Release your features faster and with less risk with ConfigCat.
ConfigCat能让你以更快的速度发布功能、在生产环境中进行测试，并轻松实现版本回滚。凭借ConfigCat简单的API和清晰的文档，你只需几分钟就能搭建并运行最初的概念验证（PoC）。在几分钟内轻松培训新团队成员，因此你无需为不断增长的团队支付额外费用。凭借简单的用户界面，整个团队都能高效使用它。无论你是个人还是团队，都可以通过永久免费计划来试用它。使用ConfigCat，以更快的速度和更低的风险发布你的功能。
Check them out today at configcat.com. Cool. Yeah. For people who don't know what feature flags are, it's, you know, imagine you have something out in production and you want to change some kind of behavior. So you might say, you know, now use this other database, but then you do that and then it broke in and now you've broken it for everybody. And that's, that's kind of a nightmare. So, so what you want to do instead is you want to try something out on like a few people and then slowly kind of add more and more and more people.
今天就访问 configcat.com 了解它们吧。酷。是的。对于那些不知道什么是功能标志（Feature Flags）的人来说，你可以想象一下，假设你的产品已经上线了，而你想改变某种行为。所以你可能会说：“现在改用另一个数据库了。”但当你这么做时，结果它崩溃了，现在你把所有人的服务都弄瘫痪了。而这，这简直是一场噩梦。所以，你想做的是去尝试在少数人身上做测试，然后慢慢增加更多、更多、更多的人。
And one way to do that is to have a feature flag. Have a flag that says, if this is part of my test group of people, then switch to the new database. Otherwise, use the old database. And slowly that if becomes true for more and more people. And so ConfigCast is a service that kind of handles a lot of that for you. So they can like handle deciding like who gets the feature and who doesn't. And then you can go in their UI and change all of that and slowly, slowly get it to 100%.
实现这一点的方法之一就是拥有一个功能标志。设置一个标志，内容为：如果此人属于我的测试用户群，则切换到新数据库。否则，使用旧数据库。慢慢地，这个“if”条件对越来越多的人变为真。因此，ConfigCat就是一个能帮你处理很多此类繁琐事务的服务。所以它们可以帮你处理决定谁能体验该功能、谁不能。然后你就可以进入他们的用户界面更改所有这些设置，慢慢地、逐步地将其推送到100%。
And they take a lot of that burden off you. So check them out. They're great. All right. So we could jump into trees why are trees important why are trees important so so uh just a quick story you know a lot of search indexes and e-commerce sites so if you go to amazon or you go to google or you go to any of these websites you know they need to serve content to you really quickly.
它们为你卸下了大量负担。所以去看看吧，它们真的很棒。好了。我们可以跳到树（Tree）的话题了。为什么树很重要？为什么树很重要？所以，呃——简单讲个故事，你知道，很多搜索引擎和电商网站——如果你去亚马逊、谷歌或者任何这些网站，你知道的，它们需要非常快速地向你提供内容。
And the way that you can do that, especially in a place where you're adding a lot of content, it's very dynamic. You're going to be using hash tables, which we'll talk about another time, and trees and especially trees. And so for this reason, you could say money grows on trees. If you work for Amazon, money literally grows on B trees. And so that's why it's so important. If you're going to be doing queries, insertions, if you're going to be doing partitioning of data, you are going to use trees a lot and they are extremely important. They're going to come up all the time. I think it's also one of the first things people learn in computer science. And you get this, if you look on the internet, you get the, why if I interview at X tech company, do they ask me about binary trees or about linked
而你能做到这一点的方式，尤其是在不断添加大量内容、高度动态的场景下，你会使用哈希表（我们改天再谈）以及树，特别是树。正因如此，你可以说“金钱长在树上”。如果你为亚马逊工作，金钱字面意义上就长在B树（B-Trees）上。这就是为什么它们如此重要。如果你要做查询、插入，如果你要做数据的分区，你会大量使用树，它们极其重要。它们会一直出现。我认为这也是计算机科学中人们学到的最早的东西之一。你会在网上看到这种现象：“为什么我去某某科技公司面试时，他们会问我关于二叉树或链表的问题？”
lists? And I somewhat, I hear, and I don't want to get into the drama or the politics or whatever around all of that. But what I'll say is that, you know, being able to think through trees and their trade-offs and, um, so it's just like, it's part of, you know, kind of like the problem solving, even if like Jason and I were talking before. So some of these trees we're going to talk about, I definitely use and use them all the time, but the sort of basic vanilla binary tree that most people are introduced to first, like I actually have trouble coming up with exactly how I would use that one. And it's not clear that it has a ton of use. But as a learning tool or reasoning tool or thinking tool or like a minimum backstop, like I got to at least do better than this,
我多少也听说过，我不想卷入关于这一切的戏剧争端或政治风波中。但我要说的是，能够理清树及其权衡取舍，呃，这就像是——它是（你知道的）问题解决能力的一部分，正如杰森和我之前讨论的那样。我们接下来要谈论的一些树，我确实经常使用它们；但大多数人最初接触的基本普通二叉树，我其实很难想出具体该如何使用它。而且它是否有大量实际用途也并不明朗。但作为一个学习工具、推理工具、思考工具，或者作为一个最低底线——“我至少得做到比这更好”——它确实服务于一个非常好的目的。
it actually serves a really good purpose. Yeah, yeah, totally. I think that, I mean, the thing that trees teach people at a fundamental level is the idea of sort of divide and conquer and also like agglometric thinking. So we'll jump into like how trees are built. And hopefully, like, we can use that to kind of motivate why they're so important to know about. So, you know, imagine if you have, you know, some set of numbers and you need to put this set of numbers into a tree and we'll get into why you'd want to do that later. But imagine, you know, your task is sort of doing this. You have this binary tree and you want to, you know, you want to fill it full of these numbers and you want the tree to be pretty balanced and stuff like that. So there's two kind of ways to do this. One way is a sort of divide and conquer. So you can imagine
是的，完全如此。我认为，树在根本层面上教给人们的是“分治”（divide and conquer）的思想，还有算法思维。所以我们要深入探讨树是如何构建的。希望我们可以用这一点来解释为什么了解它们如此重要。所以，你知道的，想象一下如果你有一些数字，你需要把这组数字放进一棵树里——我们稍后会讨论你为什么想这么做。但想象一下，你的任务就是做这件事。你有一棵二叉树，你想把它填满这些数字，并且你希望这棵树相当平衡，诸如此类。所以有两类方法可以做到这一点。一种方法是“分治”法。你可以想象
saying, well, what I'll do is I'll, I'll start with all my numbers. So I kind of, in a way have like a single node that just has my entire set of numbers in it. And then what I'll do is I'll just split the set into two halves. You know, one half is the bottom 50% of numbers, right? The bottom half of the numbers, if I was to order them, like maybe you'll sort them and then cut that sorted list in half. And then say, you know, I'll send that half down the left side of the tree. And I'll send the bigger half down the right side of the tree. And maybe i'll take the node that's right in the on the median and make that my node so you know imagine like you have 20 as the root of the tree and everything to the right of 20 is bigger everything's left to 20 is smaller and so now you can repeat that process again on the left and right side right you have a little
这样说：“好吧，我要做的是，我从所有的数字开始。”所以某种程度上，我有一个单独的节点，里面包含了我的整组数字。然后我要做的是，我把这个集合分成两半。你知道的，其中一半是数值最小的50%，也就是数字的下半部分，如果我对它们进行排序的话——也许你会先排序，然后把排序后的列表切成两半。接着说：“你知道的，我把那一半发往树的左侧，把较大的一半发往树的右侧。”也许我会把正处于中位数位置的那个节点作为我的根节点。所以，你知道的，想象一下20作为树的根节点，20右边的所有东西都更大，20左边的所有东西都更小。现在你可以在左侧和右侧重复这个过程，对吧？你的数据集大小比原来减半，但过程保持不变。如果你只看那包含了一半数字的左侧分支并将其孤立地来看，你会发现你面临的问题其实和最初完全一样，只不过数字变少了。所以树是解释递归、处理所有这些现象以及涵盖计算机科学中许多其他现象的绝佳方式，对吧？所以树就像是——你甚至可以把递归时的调用图和我们进行计算的过程看作是这样一棵树，也就是你调用过的所有函数的历史。所以，是的，树是无处不在的。因此它为你打开了
less than half the size of your original set, but that process stays the same. And if you were to just go to that left branch that has that half of numbers and just look at it in isolation, you actually have the same problem as you did in the very beginning, just with fewer numbers. And so trees are a really good way to explain recursion and to, you know, deal with all of that phenomena and to cover a lot of other phenomena in computer science, right? So trees are kind of, you can even think of like the call graph when you're doing recursion and we're doing computation as sort of this tree, like the history of all the functions you've called. So yeah, trees are kind of ubiquitous. And so it kind of like introduces
通往计算机科学许多其他领域的大门。现在，构建树的另一种方法是我们所谓的凝聚层次聚类（agglomerative）或自底向上（bottom-up）的方法。嗯，要以一种凝聚的方式做同样的事情，你可能会说：“我要获取我所有的数字，对它们进行排序，然后把它们分组为16个不同的组。”然后对于其中的每一组，我要挑出一个数字并把它作为该组的叶子节点（leaf node）。接着我要这样做，然后自底向上地开始将这些小树合并在一起。所以现在就像是我有一堆这样的小树，我要把它们合并、合并、合并。等我完成时，我就得到了一棵大树。这就是组装这些树的
you to a lot of other areas of computer science. Now, another way to build trees is what we call agglometric or bottom up. Well, to do the same thing in like an agglometric way, you might say, I'm going to take all my numbers, I'm going to sort them, and then I'm going to group them into, you know, 16 different groups. And then for each of those groups, I'm going to, you know, pick a number out and put it and call it like the leaf node of that group. And then I'm going to, you know, do that and then kind of go bottom up and then start kind of merging some of these mini trees together. So now it's like I have a bunch of these smaller trees. I'm going to kind of merge them, merge them, merge them. Then when I'm done, I have one big tree. And that's kind of the
凝聚方法。这也是——如果你看一下归并排序（merge sort）或类似的东西，你实际上会发现这两种情况，对吧？所以在归并排序中，你首先是将一个列表对半拆分，然后对半拆分、对半拆分，就是这种连续减半的算法。然后在某个时刻，你达到了一个所有列表的大小都为1的点。接着你开始合并、合并、合并。所以，你知道的，归并排序实际上兼具了
agglometric way of assembling these trees. And so that is also, if you look at, for example, merge sort or something like that, you actually see kind of both of these things, right? So in merge sort, you start by kind of splitting a list into halves and then halving it, halving it, halving it, just these successive halving algorithm. And then at some point, you reach a point where it's just all just lists of size one. And then you start kind of merging, merging, merging. And so, you know, Merge Short actually has both, you know, a divide and conquer approach
分治方法和凝聚方法，将所有东西重新组合在一起。但当它们重新组合时，它们就已经是有序的了。哦，我不知道这还有个名字。对，对，所以它是——然后你就会面临这样一个问题：“你究竟该如何去进行那种拆分呢？”比如，如果数据很小——比方说，你有100个项目，你正把它们放进某种二叉树中，那么你可以像我们讨论的那样：先排序，然后拆分，你就会得到一棵极其平衡的树，
and then an agglometric approach to kind of bring everything back together. But when it comes back together, it comes back sorted. Oh, I didn't know that had a name yeah yeah so so it's uh so then then you have this question of like how do you go about doing that divide right like if it's if it's small you know like for example you know you have 100 items and you're just putting it into some binary tree well then you can you can kind of what we talked about sort it and then split it and you'll have this like perfectly balanced tree
看起来会非常漂亮。但在实践中，你处理的是海量、海量的数据集。所以你实际上做不到这一点。这在现实中说不通。你甚至可能会遇到多模态或多目标的数据。所以可能会有不同的方法来拆分数据。
and it'll look really nice. But in practice, you're dealing with like massive, massive data sets. And so you can't really do that. It doesn't really make sense. You might even have things that are multi kind of modal or multi-objective. So there might be different ways to split data.
你知道的，也许你有一个人的列表。这些人有年龄、有性别、还有其他特征。而你想要构建一棵二叉树，它能最终产生大小相等的不同人群的分桶。所以你的二叉树可能会这样说：“好吧，让我们首先看所有年龄在18岁以上的人在一边，所有18岁以下的人在另一边；所有在过去一天里访问过我网站的人在一边。”所以在这种决策树中，在所有这些决策的末尾，在提出所有这些问题之后，你现在拥有了这个终端状态，
You know, maybe you have a list of people. And those people have, you know, ages, they have genders, they have other characteristics. And you want to have some binary tree that says, you know, that ultimately, like like results in different equally sized buckets of people. So your binary tree might say something like, well, let's first look at everyone who's over 18 is on one side and everyone who's under 18 is on the other side. And it's everyone who has been to my website in the past day is on one side. And so in this kind of decision tree, at the end of all of these decisions, at the end of asking all of these questions, you now have this, you know, end state, which
希望里面不会包含太多人。所以，无论你是在做这样的决策树，还是在对一个非常大的数据集做排序树，你都无法尝试构建该树的所有可能方式。那成本太高了。我认为想出最好的可能决策树是NP困难（NP-hard）的问题。所以这就是为什么你最终会尝试使用其中一些近似方法。因此你可能会尝试——在树的每个节点上，你可能会尝试50种或100种不同的拆分方式。虽然可能有成千上万种，但你只尝试50种。正因为你只尝试50种，你可能就不会，
hopefully doesn't have too many people in it. And so, you know, whether you're doing a decision tree like that, or you're doing just a, you know, a sorted tree, but of a really large data set. You can't try every possible way to construct that tree. It's just too expensive. I think it's like MP hard, like coming up with the best possible decision tree. And so that's where you end up with trying to do some of these approximations. So you might try, you know, at every node in the tree, you might try 50 or 100 different ways of splitting it. Now, there might be thousands, but you're just going to try 50. And because you're trying 50, you might not, you know,
希望里面不要有太多人。所以，你知道，无论你是在做这样的决策树，还是只是在做一个针对超大数据集的排序树。你不可能尝试所有可能的树构建方法。这代价太高了。我想这就像是NP难问题，比如找出最优的决策树。所以这就是你最终尝试使用其中一些近似方法的原因。因此，你可能会尝试，你知道的，在树的每个节点上，你可能会尝试50种或100种不同的分裂方法。现在，可能有几千种，但你只会尝试50种。而且因为你尝试了50种，你可能不会，你知道的，
get the best way of splitting, but hopefully the best one out of 50 is decent. And then when you go to all these children that you've created from the split, you're going to do this again. And you're going to pick 50 at random, a different 50 ways of splitting. And if there was a really good way of splitting that you missed, hopefully you catch it at the next level. And so this is how a lot of these decision trees or binary trees over a really large data sets are kind of assembled. There have been a lot of other like search based approaches, but it's actually really hard to beat the just a greedy way of doing it. So to back it off of back to the kind of like the basic stuff i think jason was already jumping ahead that we are at least me i tend to think of trees as storing like strictly orderable things in the
data like numbers or strings uh and one of the other things to point out is that you may not be exposed to all of them all up front so if you are experiencing them over time having these things that jason's talking about and figuring out how you split how do you insert new data or remove data or modify data plays a part too and what tree and algorithm you might select the other thing that i that has come into play for me is that I often think about first about trees as being sort of individual allocated nodes with pointers between them. I work in C++. So that's how I think. But they don't have to be. Actually, in fact, in some cases, in many cases, it may be better served to have an array of all of your data and then order the stuff in the array where
like the zero item in the array is your root node. And then the, you know, first and second are the children nodes. And then you can do sort of what level are you on? And where in the level are you and then you can do the visitation of the nodes and the search by simply going to the right place in the array. And that has efficiencies for keeping your data, you know, more close to each other, more local, and that's more cache efficient. And we're going to get into some other things where that plays a role as well.
But I think it starts off when you're first introduced trees in my experience, like it's very rigid. They're always binary trees. In fact, they're normally always binary search trees, and you always divide them up in a certain way. But actually, the sort of body of all kinds of trees that are used in computer science is quite big. And they often share interesting similarities, but also very interesting differences. Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense.
Yeah, a lot of people have invented different trees for different specific use cases. And a lot of it comes down to, you know, being able to split the data in a way that more often than not splits evenly. Right? Because what you don't want is, and you'll hear this like trees that are balanced or unbalanced, right? So imagine if you have a binary search tree over numbers, but it's completely unbalanced. So the root node has, let's say,
you have the numbers one to 100. The root node has a one. It has just one child to the right. That's a two. And you just do this all the way to 100. Now you actually have a linked list, right? You used a tree idea, but you ended up with a linked list. And you have all the performance problems of a list, right? You used a tree idea, but you ended up with a linked list and you have all the
performance problems of a list, right? If you were expecting something to be really, really fast, you're not going to get that, you're not going to meet that expectation, right? And so you want these trees to be balanced, but you also, as we talked about before, like you can't spend a lot of time building it because you're dealing with such large volume, right? So you can't look at all the items, do many, many passes. And so a lot of these structures that we'll get into have really nice propensity to just naturally break data down into ways that are even, you know, for a specific type of problem. I mean, yeah, I think the algorithms for keeping them balanced are probably slightly difficult to communicate over audio.
Yeah. But what are some of those algorithms if people want to look them up? Yeah, it's a really good point. So in addition to like choosing the right tree, and people are inventing new types of trees all the time, you know, no matter what you do, especially if data is coming in and going out, you know, the trees will become unbalanced, either when you're building it or when you're, you know, modifying it. And so there is, you know, there are special kind of trees called AVL trees and red black trees. And for things like bee trees, there are
ways to rebalance them. But as Patrick said, I mean, you definitely take a look at if you search for any of these trees on Wikipedia or other places, you'll see really nice kind of visuals of how they're rebalanced. But I remember from undergrad, rebalancing trees is one of the hardest things that I have to implement and i just remember having so many issues because you have to kind of project yourself into different parts of the tree and like think okay at this point of the tree you know i i am like like i'm at this node in the tree but because i'm in the middle of this rebalancing, I know this, this, and this. And so I have to do that. And so that stuff gets really, really difficult. So yeah, I think in general, if you're going to use trees, try to find a library on the web. Definitely take the time to
understand how they work. But if you're going to put something into production, there should be a really good implementation of a variety of different trees that's publicly available. Looking at binary trees specifically, a binary tree is one where you only have two children. And so you might say to yourself, well, why would I have that restriction? Why would I, why would I, you know, have that restriction, right? Like what's, what's, why would I limit myself, right? But there is one thing that binary trees can do really, really well. And that is like upper or lower bound search, right? So for example, imagine if you have a set of numbers and you're asking the question, you know, what is the biggest number in my set, you know, less than 30, right? That question requires you to do kind of an in-order search. So you have to kind of look for
30. If you find 30, well, I guess I said less than. So yeah, even if you find 30, you still have to kind of go backwards and find the biggest number less than 30. So you have to kind of march in sorted order through that structure, right? And a binary tree is really nice because since there's only two children, you know that the child to the left is smaller. And assuming there's no duplicates in the tree, the child to the left is smaller and the child to the right is bigger. And that's always true. And you can also do this trick
where if you take any point in the tree, if you take the child to the left and then keep going to the right as many times as you can, you're going to get the number that is smaller than the one you're currently at, but bigger than all the other ones. And so that's a unique feature to binary trees. And I think that is one of the biggest reasons. Another reason why
people use binary trees is in machine learning. We talked about there's in machine learning, you're typically not using a tree to store a lot of numbers or something like that. You know, you're using a tree to the structure of the tree to store decisions. And so at the end of the leaf or the end of a binary tree, if you've searched through it, you have kind of a list of constraints and you can use that as a way to learn things, right? So in that case, it's actually pretty difficult to split multiple ways, depending on what kind of decision you're making. So it's decisions like, you know, this number should be greater than X or, you know, this binary number should be set to true. These are all binary decisions like thresholds and binary operators. There might be times where you have some kind of categorical thing.
So day of the week, it could be seven choices and you should have seven children. But even in those cases, it's kind of hard to calculate whether that is a good decision to put in your tree or not. Versus if you have a binary yes-no decision, it's pretty easy to calculate. Yes, I want to take that decision and put it here in the tree. And so for that reason, a lot of machine learning will use binary trees when they're making these decision trees. You'll also hear in machine learning the term random forest. At the time, I thought random forest was this really complicated thing because I'd heard where it was used. And so I thought, oh, one of these days, I really want
to learn random forest. Random forest is very simple. All it is is if you have a big data set and you're planning on building a decision tree, instead what you can do is you can split that data set in different ways and build in different decision trees. And because of that randomness I talked earlier about where you're randomly trying different splits, even if the distributions of the data or the type of the data is the same in each of those groups, you're still going to end up with different decision trees. And then once you have all of these decision trees, when you want to make
a decision in the future, you can actually ask all of them. And then you can either do some kind of voting, or you can come up with, but one of them is a B tree. And so B trees say that each node can, and there's some variance here, but basically each node can contain multiple values. And then the, however many values it has, you have that many children plus one. So let's say you had two values stored there instead of just one, then things before the lowest value, you keep them sorted. And then the thing below the lowest value, you would have reference to the next child there. Between the two values, you would have a child. And to the right, the bigger, the biggest, larger than the two of the bigger, you would have a child to your right. So in that case, you had two values in the node and three children.
And you could see this expanding to various sizes, four, five, six, seven. And there's a lot of varieties and some techniques for how you keep them balanced. But the interesting thing about here is when you visit a node, rather than simply making a single decision, do I use this value? Do
I go to left or right? You sort of can consult multiple values. And then also, by doing that, you make your tree shallower. So you don't have as many levels of children as you would if you used a binary tree because you're putting more data in the node. Now, the other thing that I already hinted at as well, where this starts to matter, and this is one of those things where when I'm doing interviews with people, and we do some sort of, you know, questions, and we're working through a problem, and then I'll often ask them, you know, oh, what is sort of the runtime? And they start scratching their head, and this is different for everyone, but I always express to them, look, I'm actually not that interested
in sort of the academic asymptotic runtime because it turns out like in my life, most of the time you're dominated by other factors. So I'm looking for you to just express to me like which parts of this algorithm about how many times would this take? Where are your bottlenecks? And so one of the things that B-trees really excel at
is if you imagine, which was true, maybe a lot more true five, 10 years ago than is true today. But if you go back 10 years, RAM was really small. Like CPU caches weren't really like they are today. And things were stored on sectors on hard drives. And if you were going to go access something on the hard drive, the hard drive was going to spin up, move the little arm
out to the right spot on the moving piece of metal with magnetized bits on it and read in a whole bunch of data in a sector and bring that into memory. And that was an extremely slow thing. And so if you were going to do an on disk search for data, you wanted to bring in sort of as much in one go as you can. And if you imagine a binary tree, where at each block, you have one, and then the next block is who knows where, each time you go to the next node, you are spending a lot of time waiting to get the next node into memory, or getting into the CPU. And these B-trees became very valuable by instead saying, we're going to store a whole bunch of data in the sector, and then we're going to
analyze all that data, increase our chances at any given node of finding ours, or at least cutting down the search set dramatically so the number of different nodes we have to visit is as small as possible. So for things like file system and file system metadata, for things like databases and indexes and databases, these B-trees get used heavily because you can tune the number of children and you can do sort of more work per node visitation. And if node visitation at a certain spot, that you know how to keep it ordered and organized and well balanced. And so there's a whole body of work around bee trees, but it's enormously valuable in this sort of broadening the scope out from just one value and two children to allowing a more general form and realizing that that may play better with an
actual computer architecture. Yeah, really well said. Yeah, that really covers it. And so, yeah, as Patrick said, I mean, pretty much any database that you look at is going to have a B-tree implementation in it. I mean, all of them, they all use B-trees in some way, shape, or form. So now we'll move on to spatial trees. And as we motivated earlier, spatial trees often aren't functionally that different in terms of their idea, but they're just taking advantage of some domain knowledge. In this case, the fact that it's operating over some space or some field, right? And so the simplest one of these that I know of is a KD tree. I don't actually know where the name KD came from, but effectively it's a binary tree where every split is done on a single axis. And so if you imagine like, so like picture in your mind, you know, a graph, like just with an X and a Y, right, graphing some function. If you just
have a line, right, you can describe a line just by looking at one of the two letters. So if you look at just a horizontal or a vertical line, you can do that just by looking at one of the two variables, right? So if I have a line like y equals x or a parabola like y equals x squared, I need to be thinking about y and x at the same time because they kind of relate to each other. So y equals x squared, you know, as x is increasing, y is really increasing. And so you have this like parabola right this line that like just shoots upwards right but if i have a just a vertical line that's just like x equals two and i want all the y's right that's a vertical line or if i have a
horizontal line that would be you know like y equals four and so and i just want all the x's that are all points on that line. So vertical and horizontal lines are kind of the easiest to express, right? And so KD tree uses this to, um, you know, to, to have a very simple division of, of, of the space. So what a KD tree, KD tree will do when you're building one is you'll look over all the points and let's just keep it at two dimensions just to keep it simple so you'll look over at all these points and then you'll calculate the spread in other words you calculate the difference between the smallest point and the biggest point on that dimension so if you were imagining like uh you know a bunch of points but
but they're all kind of around the same height, but there are some that are really far to the left, some that are really far to the right. You have this really large horizontal spread, but not a very large vertical spread. And so whichever dimension has the largest spread, that one's going to be chosen as your split dimension. So you're going to choose that dimension, and then you're going to split it right in the middle. Now, when I say in the middle, I don't mean like in the middle of the extremes, but you're going to split it such that half the points go on the left and half the points go on the right. And so while you're computing the spread, you can also be, you know,
finding that middle, finding that median median point so if you imagine the root node the root node is going to look at your entire data set find which dimension has the largest spread and then slice that dimension such that half the points go to one child and half the points go to the other child and then all that root node needs to keep track of is which dimension it was split on and where in that dimension the split was. Now, then each of the children will do the same thing. And so you'll keep doing this until you get to a node where there aren't that many children. At that point, you'll say, well, there's no point in me splitting again. I'm just going to have like just a list of points at that level. And so KD trees are super, super important because there's a really, really cool trick you could do with them.
In machine learning, you have this challenge, right? Where let's say you're Amazon, right? And someone types in batteries. And so you need to return back a list of items that you think that person would be interested in, right? But the problem is Amazon has like a billion items, right? Or maybe even if you take it even more extreme, let's say someone just goes to amazon.com. They don't even put a search. So you need to show them some items you think they would like. And there's just so many items, probably a billion SKUs in Amazon's catalog, right? So you can do this trick. Let's say you had a vector, a vector, just like a set of numbers. Let's say you had a set of numbers to describe a person, right? And so
you know, that might be sort of like some way of capturing like their history and the things you think they like. And you were to sort of what's called embed that or create just like a single point for that person. And then you also do this for all your different products. So for all your different products, you have kind of like a point or a vector, a list of numbers or a to this person point that I've created. And it turns out if you use a KD tree, you can do that very, very, very quickly. Things like nearest neighbor search can happen extremely quickly in a KD tree because, for example, look at that first split. That first split might be like so far away from where the person point is that you could say anything on the other side of that split, there's no way that any of those points are my nearest neighbor. And so that's
right away, that's half the data you don't have to look at. Right. And so you can kind of take that sort of intuition that basically, you know, you can kind of follow the KD tree down to the, you know, final part of the KD tree that has your person in it, your person point in it, and look at the products there. And then maybe look at like some of the products, you know, higher up in the tree, but you definitely don't have to look at the entire tree. You can ignore 99% of the tree. And so this is how Amazon does at the end of the day, this is how they can show you stuff so quickly, even though they have so many items. And so there's a lot of work that goes into like the embeddings and how you create
the tree and everything, but ostensibly, you know, they're, they just have a giant KD tree that they've implemented. And when you come to Amazon, they find the nearest things to you in that tree. That's how it works. So to highlight one difference and then talk about one final thing, I think when Jason is describing like this nearest neighbor search on multi dimensions, which we sort of call these spatial trees, because that tends to be one way of thinking about it. But when we're talking up front about B trees and binary trees, we're talking about a single number line, basically, where all of your elements live on. And when we talk about multidimensional, it's having at least two or more dimensions. And the problem there becomes,
there isn't a strict way of viewing, like, I'm just going to go in dimension one and then dimension two. Like, that turns out to be really inefficient. So both Katie, Jason, and things I'm going to talk about and some others try to divvy up the space in a way that moves back and forth between the dimensions. And as Jason was saying, using the spread, you might divide on the X line, the X line, but then you'll go by the Y line, right? And you're sort of intermixing the two dimensions and trying to sort of interleave so that you can get to your answer a little bit faster. And when you're traversing, the other interesting thing is you may end up having to go through multiple branches in order to find the nearest neighbor. So once you go down one branch, you know how far away the split was from you.
And if your answer ends up being further away than that split was, you actually have to go visit the stuff on the other side of that split. And that's true as well for a variety of these facial trees and doing that nearest neighbor search. And the other thing that both his KD tree explanation and my, oh man, I guess I did
this out of order. Anyways, the thing I'm about to talk about also support, which is very similar, is for querying ranges. Or if you think about in 2D, it would be rectangles or boxes, right? So if you drew a rectangle and said, I want everything inside of this rectangle, they need to be efficient at doing that. And it's a little hard to describe over audio, but I mean, both of them are well-suited to being able to do that. So Jason talked about splitting the data on one of the axes at each level. So instead of looking at your data
and sort of splitting based on what the data says, instead, if you come up with predefined splits based on your space, you come up with a different spatial tree called a quad tree for two dimensions or an octree for three dimensions. I don't know what it would be for four dimensions. I've never heard of someone doing that, but maybe you could. And so if you imagine in two dimensions having, let's just say a square, right? And you divide that square once in the middle up and down and once in the middle left and right then you end up with four quadrants of that space and now you see why it's called a
quadri so the root node would be the base sort of square then the first set of children there would be four and one would be the upper left one would be the upper right one would be the bottom left and one would be the bottom right and what would be the bottom left, and one would be the bottom right. And what that does is that sort of dimension mixing I was talking about, you get it, right? So as you go, you know, child 0, 1, 2, 3, you're actually traversing both dimensions sort of intermixed. But the quad tree, what it does is say, if I have a set of points scattered around in my square, I'm going to keep subdividing my space until I get, you could say, just one thing in each square. So the disadvantage is that as you're cutting down and down and down, if you have two points really close to each other, you might need a lot of splits before you get to the split that separates the two. And so you could have a lot of depth before you get to the split that separates the two. And so you could have a lot of depth, right? But in traversing, it actually ends up working really similar to how the KD tree does.
The advantage of a quad tree is that I can figure out where in the tree it goes from the start. So if I know the level I want to go to, like let's say level five split, I can compute in closed form which traversal of the tree I would need to place that element in the tree there. The other nice thing is that if you have dynamic data where your data is moving around, so imagine like someone shoots a laser beam out of your spaceship in your game and you have your world game split up in a quad tree or if it's in three dimensions, an octree, which is the same thing, but with eight children, if you imagine that laser bolt moving through space and needing to do these nearest neighbor queries, which is what you would want to do if you wanted to see like if I hit something in my current box, then this traversal you can figure out in sort of a more direct closed form
computation and do the management in a sort of much cheaper way rather than reshuffling and potentially needing to re-split like you would need to for a KD tree or other kinds of spatial trees that would be used. So they're similar in actually the way you use it. And once you start looking at algorithms between them, like once you figured it out once, it kind of ends up being pretty similar for all of them and how to do these range searches and nearest neighbor searches. I find that these quad trees and octrees are used a lot in games for dynamic data. And the quad tree, KD tree, there's also one more that's worth mentioning, I guess, which is like an R tree, which is taking a group of data and drawing a rectangle around it, and then building a tree of rectangles over multiple rectangles. And I won't go into it more than that. And you'll see that also used a lot in sort of mapping data,
geographical or geographic information systems, GIS systems. We'll use these a lot in databases and stuff. Also, I think KD trees can also be used in video games. I've seen them used for like splitting up a level and understanding which polygons you want to draw or not, because the level itself, like the environment tends to be static. And so you can a priori before you're like when you're making your level, you can do the split and have it stored so that when you're trying to figure out which polygons to render, you just traverse this pre-made tree rather than having to build it at runtime.
Yeah, totally. Yeah, I think, yeah, you really hit the nail on the head. I think KD trees and R trees, the structure of the tree is dependent on the data. So, you know, as Patrick said, if your data is like really wide, you might have a lot of vertical splits before you start seeing some horizontal splits. If data is really narrow, it's going to be the opposite. And yeah, in the case of the archery, you know, if there's a part of the space that's very dense, I mean, imagine building an archery of the US, right? You're going to have like a ton of rectangles around like New York City, San Francisco, Los Angeles, right? Because I mean, imagine you're building an archery on like over like businesses or addresses in the US, right? There's just a lot more addresses in a tiny space
in New York City, right? And so the structure of the tree will, you know, even all the way up to the decisions made at the very top will be influenced heavily by the distribution of the data versus like in the case of a quad tree, you know, now there might be nodes that exist or don't exist because of the data, but the structure, like the, the way that the splits are done is totally immutable and it has nothing to do with, with the data. Right. And so, you know, that's sort of like a double-edged sword, right? On one hand, if you're not splitting in an informed way, then you're not going to be very efficient. And so if you're doing something just once, like if you're creating a tree off some
data that's not changing and then using it a lot of times like that's what amazon is doing you know amazon will create this giant tree and that might take a lot of time but then they're going to swap it out with the old tree and then they're going to use that new tree you know billions and billions of times and so they you know they can afford to have this sort of frozen set, right? And so they'll use like a KD tree or an R tree or something like that. But for games, the content is moving all the time. I mean, there's, as Patrick said, like if you have people walking around on a map, shooting laser beams and all these things,
then you can't have the structure of the tree dependent on these things that are constantly moving around. And so for games, they'll use these octrees and quad trees. And my guess is, and I think you alluded to this Patrick is, you know, games will probably need both because the level doesn't move unless you're playing like Minecraft or something, but the other, the level doesn't, the geometry doesn't change.
then you can't have the structure of the tree dependent on these things that are constantly moving around. And so for games, they'll use these octrees and quad trees. And my guess is, and I think you alluded to this Patrick is, you'll games will probably need both because the level doesn't move unless you're playing like Minecraft or something, but the other, the level doesn't, the geometry doesn't change.
And so that would be much better served by something like a kd tree or r tree and there's actually more like exotic trees for certain domains there's like a bsp tree there's uh you know vantage point trees and so they'll use something like that and but then for actually storing all of the dynamic content they'll use something like an oak tree. That was a lot of fun. Yeah, we totally got to geek out on trees. If we missed any trees, let us know. Pine trees, oak trees.
所以用k维树或R树之类的东西会好得多，而且实际上针对某些领域还有更奇特的树，比如BSP树、视点树之类的，它们会使用类似的东西，但对于实际存储所有的动态内容，它们会使用八叉树之类的东西。这真的很有趣。是的，我们彻底探讨了各种树。如果我们漏掉了什么树，请告诉我们。松树，橡树。
Yeah, that's right. Birch. Minecraft taught me a lot about trees. I've been playing that a lot with the kids. I learned that birch is a thing. I don't quite know the order, the big O notation of that birch is a thing. So I don't quite know like the order, the big O notation of a birch. We'll have to figure that one out. But thank you so much, everyone,
是的，没错。桦树。我的世界（Minecraft）教给了我很多关于树的知识。我和孩子们经常玩那个游戏。我知道了桦树是存在的。我不太清楚桦树的大O符号阶数。所以我也说不准桦树的时间复杂度。我们得弄清楚这一点。但非常感谢大家，
for all of your support. Let us know what you think about the duo episodes. I mean, we're bringing them back. We still have a lot of really awesome interviews lined up. So, you know, looking forward to that. But we'll be, you know, get looking forward to that. But we'll be kind of intermixing some of these, you know, duo episodes in there and definitely give us some feedback. We really appreciate all the feedback you have been giving and just keep it up. Let us know what you think about the show.
感谢你们所有的支持。让我们知道你们对双人对谈节目的看法。我的意思是，我们将它们带回来了。我们仍然安排了许多非常棒的访谈。所以，敬请期待。但是我们会，你知道的，敬请期待。我们会把其中一些双人节目穿插在里面，一定要给我们一些反馈。我们非常感谢大家一直以来给出的所有反馈，请继续保持。让我们知道你们对节目的看法。
We definitely look at all of them. We've gotten a lot of our show ideas from listeners. This was one that we really wanted to do ourselves, but we've taken a lot of really great show topics from listeners. And that's all because of you and continuing support and feedback. So we appreciate it. Yeah. Thanks, everyone. See you later. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们绝对会查看所有的反馈。我们的许多节目创意都来自于听众。这是我们自己非常想做的一个，但我们也采纳了许多来自听众的非常棒的节目主题。这全都是因为你们以及你们持续的支持和反馈。所以我们非常感激。是的。谢谢大家。再见。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 制作。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行重混和改编，但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。